that you you would never hit it and
quite it I like what I like you know I
mean and I just like I like building a
bond with certain people and casual
relation it's like converting people to
Christianity because all I do that's my
move man what would you do what would
you do David oh it's easy this dude gets
everywhere it's not it's not easy it's
more like definitely I already had a
conversation with Mariel about this I
was like if one of us happens to die
just but we have a very casual
conversation I told him for sure I don't
think I would be in a serious
relationship for at least like six or
seven years the point developed like
five strong years with her and I have to
do all that [ __ ] over again are you
[ __ ] crazy yeah that's that's a I
think about that a lot and I think I
can't do it I don't have the strength I
think about all the stuff that means if
went through for us to kind of be where
we're at today yeah it's a lot of
[ __ ] words I can't figure out when
they're gonna have their period and
that's hard man but then like hot like
like dealing with somebody else and then
like building a new relationship with
somebody oh and you gotta figure out how
personal trauma that they had in their
past generation with their father and
their mother I don't care anymore
they're our friends now they want to
talk to me about their life problems I'm
like [ __ ] you I had this lady I have to
deal with she takes all my energy so
whatever I have left is then yours
but until then [ __ ] off yeah I I don't
care I don't care I don't care I really
don't but I don't know if I'd uh get
into a certian relationship after but
for sure just go right back a dating Pat
what's the longest relationship you've
been in six days probably like two years
you're gonna have two years I mean Emily
I lived with her it all together for
like a year and a half two years fell
apart living with somebody is [ __ ]
hard dude let me guess a party except I
have living together it's just like well
I mean a lot of things we were kind of
like incompatible in certain ways but
like when we were just dating it was
cool but like when you live with
somebody it's like damn you like you
just can't get a [ __ ] like they're
always that always but that happened
quick though too and it's like you have
to know somebody she also caught me
watching porn in that what's the problem
that she used to think porn was cheating
what so yeah I dude there's a whole
there's a whole [ __ ] thing so she
thought Patrick it is virtue honor
of our relationship I remember I made a
joke about porn like this is a still in
the getting-to-know-you face we hadn't
like hooked up or anything yeah and she
was like dude she was like porn is
disgusting and I was like I mean you'd
sure she was she was like now like porn
she's like I think porn is cheating and
I was like that's like I was like that's
pretty extreme you're like that's
[ __ ] stupid that's what you said and
she said well if you watch porn we could
just stop talking right now so she's not
gonna date anybody dude I'm gonna start
dating girls probably by the way ladies
if you meet a guy and you guys are
having a conversation let's say you met
this dude on tinder all right ponder
ugandan under you're talking and he says
to you point blank to your face he goes
I don't watch porn that stuff is
disgusting he is watching children porn
he is masturbating to little kids faces
and on top of that he's a rapist because
the yeah he's everybody cuz for me I
could I could confidently say I don't
watch as much porn as I used to does not
mean I don't watch porn right yeah I
mean I don't watch as much as I used to
still watch it every now and then of
course it's not as normal yeah that's
what I but in that moment because it was
the beginning where I was still like
damn I wanna hook up with this girl I
would like I don't really watch like
I've seen it but like I don't know I try
to make me watch it I cover my butt
that's a bro good answer but then we
ended up living together and then she
caught me one day what were you watching
what was her reaction to yeah what were
you watching
okay I don't remember what I was
watching but I was definitely on spank
bank calm that's one of my college it's
still up develop and run all those porn
sites are for sure have like a longevity
yeah no one's taking those down dude
pink bang so I was on that and she was
supposed to be I work till 4:00 it was
like 1:00 I didn't have a job at the
time either so it was like extra loser
what does she expect you to do that of
course you're gonna jack off the porn
you'd have a job I got a sweetie [ __ ] no
it's 1:00 p.m. I'm like [ __ ] I'm gonna
I feel like jerking off right now is
what I'm gonna do and I was done like I
was like cleaning up but I was an idiot
I left the website up and I came out I
was in my boxers and she was standing in
the living room and I was just like
you're still like half hard so your
[ __ ] picture
damn my boxers and I was like ah
you should have done is this right when
you saw the porn on the screen you
looked at it been like I can't believe
you're watching what are you doing yeah
I'm so sick of this and you start
breaking [ __ ] in the house and before
she say anything and you just leave so
what was the ripple effect after she
well okay so so the video was still like
it just [ __ ] everything up cuz like
she was like super insecure I'll get
I'll get to that in a second but like so
the video wasn't up it was off but the
ad was on like you know those [ __ ]
weirdo ads like of goblins [ __ ]
unicorns and also like it made me look
like it just like to her was like a
[ __ ] watching it's like a huge
monster but it's also like it's also
like a game every time I see that alert
[ __ ] some do that face so anyways so
okay just a [ __ ] up the trust in the
relationship and then but then that's
when I was like I had the conversation
with her then that I should have had at
the beginning which was what is the
problem what is your problem with porn
and she was like I just want to be the
only woman you desire nice try
impossible that's exactly I was like
that's not possible well this isn't a
Disney movie we're not in [ __ ] suck
yeah because I love Muriel and I want to
be with only her for the rest of my life
sure but if a nice ass walks by in that
flash moment I desire that but sure you
know any it's not a choice it's not like
I don't decide to go oh I'm gonna think
this girl's [ __ ] fine three to one
day I'm like it just like she walks in
and you're like [ __ ] like what I would
have to say some really just like non
just like the most fucked-up [ __ ] to my
head just to like Pavlov myself off of
women would you you can't it's
impossible it's not it's not possible
and that's what I was trying to explain
and I kind of [ __ ] up like I said this
I realize now that this is condescending
but at the time I thought I was just
like it weird like dudes were
straightforward like yeah it was just
cool and I was like trying to relate to
her so I was like you know what I felt
exactly the way you do right now about
not wanting your partner to desire
anyone else except I was in seventh
grade like I didn't I wasn't like I was
like I thought that in middle school but
III don't realize how much of an ass
but Alexa I said that and it definitely
didn't help my case at all and she was
like she was like now like you're
addicted she immediately said they did
relax dude she's like you wanna cheat
and I was like I don't actually jerking
off prevents like any desires of the
cheating I get it out of the way we're
cool you know what I mean but there's I
was trying to explain like you said like
I just I can't help not be attracted to
people like if if you see an attractive
dude you're gonna think that guy's
attractive oh yeah it's normal it's
normal and she was like I'm only
attracted to personality and such you
should pour [ __ ] [ __ ] I hope you walk in
front of a bus right now shikaka
is the dumb I [ __ ] hate it when
[ __ ] people do that what so today
we're just going to talk about porn
addiction is like she's like today we're
gonna check my boyfriend's browser
history and there is nothing on it he's
probably using incognito mode yeah but
she so she considered watching porn
cheating because you mentally desired
somebody else besides her it's like
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] that's like telling
me right now right that's what I love I
like chicken
right but every now and then look at
some scripts but if I dedicated myself
to chicken sometimes I'll miss it it's
like it's like somebody who's switched
to being a vegan for more reason doesn't
mean the danghang crave a steak every
now sure exactly yeah I mean yeah but
does vegan they're not eating no steak
right but they crave it now and then
yeah and it's not there's nothing wrong
with it especially like for us we're
animals like we don't control that yeah
what the teacher yeah it was really
insecure so that it's that just kind of
spiraled into a bunch of [ __ ] and I cuz
I she knows where the horn addiction is
I think she was she that was like her
auto-response - right cuz porn addiction
which I know somebody who has a porn
addiction and he's working on it right
now
and for him it was more along the lines
of like I think for him he had to
realize that it was affecting his
everyday that's what an addiction is it
affects your everyday life like
functioning
working you can't have sex with your
partner you don't find them attractive
anymore you would rather masturbate than
have sex with a person sure that's where
the addiction starts to [ __ ] you up but
it's not like she came into a room
butt-naked you're like babe got a
[ __ ] jack off like you stare at her
just to collect the information and then
you walk into a that's an addiction
right you know what I mean sure yeah she
was just jumping jumping to the to the
religious she did grow up in a religious
family but I don't think that's what it
was I mean she had issues with her dad
too and like there was there was a whole
backstory to it was your fault Patrick
it's my fault but that was the longest
relationship I've been in and porn me
jerking off is kind of what [ __ ] it
and most harmless thing ever did 28
years and still running dude yeah I love
it should have never said you weren't
gonna do it man you should just told her
just been straight up from the beginning
yeah but I wanted to [ __ ] so you want to
get it in just should have compromised
whether it's like fine I won't jack off
every time I'm horny you have to suck my
dick you have to how about that we've
only known each other for two weeks
that's how unreasonable you are yeah I
mean so I can be an unreasonable human
being as well yeah but you're upfront
with this that's that's important yeah
you got to be real when I was like like
super super fat this is like one of
those turning points where I start to
realize I was really chunky I was laying
in bed and I was breathing really hard
and I was watching some [ __ ] on my iPad
and then maralell woke up she turned
over she goes aren't you watching porn
right next to me and then she turned
grab my iPad and I was watching I was
looking at a food recipe because
Thanksgiving was coming up Thanksgiving
yeah she was like are you is this a food
recipe I'm like yep I don't got time to
match me to this is your dick out David
they were there breathing like [ __ ]
small
[Laughter]